son souvenir flotte encore partout dans
la maison
il y a un an presque jour pour jour
eliane gadet perd subitement son fils
âgé de 16 ans dans un accident de la
route
sa douleur est toujours aussi vive
aujourd'hui quand on m'a annoncé la mort
de mon fils or lui ni à peu près deux
heures du matin qu'il était de cpj
collier pour dans la nuit du 31 au 1er
janvier 2019
adrien bourne marche sur ce trottoir un
chauffeur conduisant sous l'emprise de
l'alcool perd le contrôle de son
véhicule fonce à travers le rond point
et s'écrasent contre l'enceinte du stade
il fauche au passage le jeune adrien
tous deux décède sur le coup
un an plus tard la blessure reste béante
pour ses proches françois borne n'a rien
oublié de cette nuit tragique où la vie
de sa famille a basculé c'est plus et
plus la vie qu'on avait avant sa main
plaisir maintenant c'est différent il
manque quelqu'un donc c'est il faut
apprendre à vivre avec cette nouvelle
vie et mais c'est très compliqué très
compliqué on prend pas la route ont
l'empreinte il faut savoir qu'il ya des
vies au tour donc il faut vraiment faire
attention à ça
la nuit de la saint-sylvestre reste
l'une des plus meurtrières sur les
routes entre 15 et 20 décès sont
comptabilisés chaque année alors pour
rentrer en toute sécurité
un maître mot la prudence plus que
jamais il s'agit de sensibiliser les
gens à cet esprit qu'ils doivent qui
doit changer en fait on peut faire la
fête sans voir d'alcool et si on boit
d'alcool il ya des décisions qui
s'imposent notamment pour ce qui
concerne le retour on peu près on peut
effectivement faire la fête mais si on
boit de l'alcool on peut pas conduire
donc si on peut pas conduire soit on
reste sur place soir je vais
raccompagner en hommage à son frère
françois bon on a créé cette page
facebook est une association pour
sensibiliser aux dangers de l'alcool au
volant
il espère en partageant son histoire
éviter que d'autres drames comme celui
ci se produisent